se espera primero pues que se terminen
los argumentos finales de la defensa
tanto de tierras como de velocidad que
son los dos otros acusados en este caso
los de nicolas sarkozy tuvieron lugar
ayer cuando su abogada es reclinado el
azul pidió a la corte una justicia libre
al término de esto se le dará la palabra
a los tres acusados y luego será la
presidenta de esta corte de decidir si
van a entrar a deliberar o no pero lo
cierto es que el fallo puede que no se
conozca hoy sino que se demore varios
días e incluso semanas antes de
determinar si la corte va a fallar a
favor o no de la fiscalía que pidió como
usted lo decía esos o cuatro años de
cárcel
natalia y este proceso ha dividido a la
justicia en francia- y sarkozy aún tiene
pendientes otras investigaciones
cuéntenos más al respecto
así es pues la verdad es que ha sido
sobre todo sobre lo que ha basado la
fiscalía para acusar tanto de corrupción
como de tráfico de influencias a estas
tres personas porque se trata de las
escuchas telefónicas y para el colegio
de abogados de parís se trata de una
violación del secreto profesional porque
se trata de conversaciones entre nicolas
sarkozy y su abogado de hecho este
colegio de abogados ha hecho presencia
durante las audiencias de este caso
desde la semana pasada para demostrar su
apoyo a la defensa y por otra parte pues
ha sido el fiscal que dirige la fiscalía
nacionales de finanzas la que ha venido
a apoyar a sus dos fiscales a cargo pues
de la acusación en este caso así que
como ustedes ven este caso también ha
dividido de alguna manera la justicia
acá nicolas sarkozy tiene todavía
cuentas pendientes con la justicia por
una parte sobre la financiación ilegal
de su campaña a la presidencia en 2007
todavía se investiga si recibió o no
tire dineros ilícitos o de el régimen
libio de generar
y por otra parte pues hay otro proceso
que se si está mucho más adelantado que
debe comenzar el próximo 17 de marzo
sobre la financiación de su campaña de
reelección esta vez en el 2012 cuando se
utilizaron falsas facturas para tapar
que se habían pasado sobrepasado los
topes de campaña que permite la ley aquí
en francia